first and then i would want to introduce
ourselves because i see many of
new participants today here with us
precision medicine
is changing the way we understand and
diagnose and treat as well the major
life-threatening diseases and the
transformation is driven
by high throughput molecular data that
is being collected from patients
animal models and large scale cell line
experiments
in this program we will explore how the
various omics data types generated in
these studies can be analyzed and
integrated to study the basic biology
associated with the viruses
and the hosts cancer onsets and
development
and the outcomes as well as i already
introduced myself i'm saladika ray and
i'm the omixlogic community manager
and i'm responsible for daily
interaction with thousands of users that
are a part of a bioinformatics community
managed by buying biotech so before we
start the talk i would want to introduce
us
we are a bio we are a us-based
bioinformatics company
who is working with multiple academic
and commercial collaborators to develop
easy to use analytical tools and our
mission is
to make bioinformatics more accessible
omixlogic research-based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between pine biotech
and numerous academic institutions that
have participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design as
well
omix logic is an international program
that is
running in five different regions with
over 10 000
users around the world and due to this
past growth
our team is uh working with a local and
regional coordinators
that are helping refine local program
logistics
and also leverage our online training
resources
adapting them to the needs of students
and the researchers around the world
this online program includes weekly
sessions with an instructor
online tracking and review of student
progress
access to all the resources and
materials online for
self-paced learning access to expert
guidance
and problem solving educational and
research pipelines
and also the domain data analysis on our
big data server for 15 days
let me introduce you to the program
mentors dr harpreet
has an expertise in the application of
statistical machine learning techniques
and biomedical data and the development
of prediction tools and databases
and she looks after the curriculum
development bioinformatics and data
science course development
dr mohit mazumba as he has already
introduced himself he
is an experienced prior information with
multiple publications and peer-reviewed
journals
and collaborations in industry and
academia
over the past several years he has been
developing collaborations with
universities
as a mentor and a project lead for
omixlogic training
and research fellowship we have dr
jebuliano shavers with us
he's a postdoctoral fellow at university
of chicago
and he is skilled in bioinformatics and
is an expert in glioblastoma
now i would uh want to pass it on to
ilia broadskate
ceo pine biotech to talk more about the
program over to you
thank you very much for the introduction
and welcome everyone it's excited to do
this
together today and uh what i wanted to
talk about
is a little introduction to
the precision medicine topic in general
why bioinformatics and precision
medicine
but also to tell you briefly about what
the program is going to help you with
uh when you are joining this training
program so
before i go there our background is
we're a technology transfer company and
we have a close collaboration with
university of haifa the tower
bioinformatics research center which is
a
center dedicated to the development of
computational tools and algorithms
and also making them available in a use
easy to use
way for many users that do not have an
engineering and a bioinformatics
background
and essentially the objective of the
omics logic program that we developed
is to help with training in
bioinformatics
to enable independent research that is
guided by mentors and peer example
we want to develop a community that is
thriving and growing
and they share a passion for data-driven
research and an appreciation of
citizen science which means that not
just scientists
doing science but people that are
learning about
science are also engaged in that process
and then we also want to make sure that
we are enabling students clinicians and
faculty of all backgrounds
to develop novel independent research
using latest technology in life and
data sciences which means to make it
more accessible and more
user friendly and so today we're
speaking about
precision medicine and i want to briefly
talk about
why bioinformatics and precision
medicine i mean
if you're interested in precision
medicine maybe you're a clinician maybe
you're a student in biotechnology
maybe you're just interested in
applications of
data for the biomedical research and so
the question is well why bioinformatics
so what we want to talk about today is
how
essentially the availability of data and
high throughput computational
resources and computational
resources that can analyze and integrate
and visualize this data
is actually driving a new approach
to using data for clinical purposes
and so to describe what that really
means
i want to take a couple of examples and
then i'll pass it on to
some of our mentors to speak more in
depth about their particular examples
with research studies they've
been involved in so let's take an
example with cancer right we know that
cancer incidence and mortality is
growing
specifically it is growing in countries
that have
already good health care systems they
have a lot of research
and the major driving force behind that
is the growing
and aging population so the percentage
of people that are older
typically that is seen as one of the
driving reasons why
the number of cancer patients and
mortality rates are increasing
now how do you leverage the
ability of these countries to understand
and study these diseases
to address such a pressing challenge
that is only bound to continue and grow
and become more complex in the future
well one of the things that is now
obvious about cancer
is that the earlier we understand
that cancer risk is increasing
and the earlier we can detect the
specific type of cancer
that is developing we can develop
markers of cancer risk and we start
addressing that cancer earlier on
and that is a proven way to address
cancer mortality and treatment in a more
efficacious way
and so this early diagnosis really
starts very
early and maybe for some cancers
including
cancers that children have this is a
very critical point
so we need the ability to screen
but obviously we cannot screen for
everything we need to know what we're
looking for
and so the basis of this data-driven
and biomarker-driven medicine is really
having access to data
and so in the past a couple of decades i
think the
major exciting thing that has been
happening
is that next generation sequencing as a
technology has been refined
to the point that it is becoming
accessible enough and affordable enough
so it is
really entering the clinical domain and
so it is entering
with this diversity and challenge
that a technology like next generation
sequencing
is can bring because essentially next
generation sequencing can be used
to generate a diverse set of data and so
that brings us to this point of omics
data so why
omix data and as you know we're called
onyx logic so
a lot of this program is going to be
focused on omix data so onyx
means uh a collection a collection
of the totality of something and so it
could really refer to a number of
different things
for example we can say phenomics which
is the collection of phenotypes
because really when we look at cells
let's say coming from a tumor or the
micro environment
they have different morphology they they
have different characteristics that we
can define in different ways
and so we can collectively call that
phenomics the
collection of phenotypes about a
particular organism
cell or tissue we can also generate
genomic data right so a lot of us
know about genomic data genomic medicine
essentially looking for those mutations
or finding associations between
mutations and
specific types of cancer or specific
stage of cancer or specific treatments
that might be effective or not so that's
called genomics we're looking at
mutations changes in the dna then
there's epigenetics or epigenomics a
rapidly growing field because more and
more we're understanding that
genomic regulation what's written in the
dna
is also regulated by additional elements
like
histone modification like dna
methylation
how chromatin is open or closed and how
accessible it is and many other factors
as well so
a growing area of research that
definitely has an effect
on cancer as well because we know that
cancer is driven by genetics but also by
the
environment and then transcriptomics
where we look at
gene expression alternative splicing
gene fusion
and many other interactions between mrna
and the mechanisms that are a part of
the translate
translation mechanism that turns the
written genes in the dna
into actual proteins that are being used
and not only is that a useful
proxy to look at proteins but an
important view
of what are the specific biological
processes that are happening
right now in a given group of cells
individual cells
tissues organs or the full organism and
so
what is i think exciting about
availability of this data
is that it provides us with a very
detailed
view of not only the result
the product of what is in the dna
but it actually gives us a snapshot of
what is being done right now
so if you think about how this affects
clinical use
you can imagine that if before we were
looking at express
proteins if we were looking at histology
if we were looking at morphology of the
tissue and differences
in the phenotype now we can look deeper
in
inside every single cell and we can
actually understand what is going on
there
right now so how is this changing cancer
treatment well one important factor is
is that it is actually right now
changing
breast cancer classification as one
example so
not only are we looking at the changing
practices
in the clinic because of next generation
sequencing data but we're actually
looking at an active area of research
that makes
a lot of these clinical approaches to
treatment
diagnosis and prevention of cancer a
dynamic area of research
and so we're really looking at now how
we can look at
histological classification functional
classification
and molecular classification together by
integrating multiple types of omics data
through omics
integration but also then how to use
machine learning on
large data sets that we already have
available
to integrate and make sense of this data
in the context of disease classification
but also
for individual patients and i think
that's why
really we're looking at a an
important and a growing role of
bioinformatics and informatics and data
science in general
in this clinical field so it's really
about
bridging the early stage basic
research using this data to translate
this research
to practice and understand how different
aspects of omix data
could be applied in practical clinical
situations
now that's one level of complexity
multiple omics multiple types of
challenges but another one is that
really we need to connect
how this basic type of research really
connects
to what we see in patients and typically
that means
how do we translate insights from
patient-derived cell lines
to studies that are being performed on
animal models
to then the application of that
information for clinical trial
trials and also into the clinic which is
the ultimate goal of genomic
a good example of that and how it is
changing not
only with omni's data but with omix data
as well is this application and here's
an
example where we are looking at existing
types of cancers we're looking at
new types of disease states that we can
identify
and ultimately instead of approaching
that from a
typical clinical perspective we're
really looking at a data-driven
perspective where we are trying to
actually leverage the availability of
data and a lot of that data is available
in many different repositories and i'll
briefly mention that
to essentially speed up the
the new uh development of treatments
and clinical applications to leverage
that data
treat patients better develop new or
repurpose
drugs to treat the disease better
and also to even prevent data by
understanding better
what are the driving risks behind many
of these
types of diseases so as i mentioned
surprisingly
not only is this data available
the availability of data is growing at a
rapid speed and so what we see
especially in this pandemic right we've
seen how
the availability of genomic data not
only is it growing in volume
it is also growing in how fast it is
becoming available right so if you
imagine
as somebody who is maybe a student or a
clinician
you know where do i get all of this data
right so there's so much data becoming
available
every day that we can mine
and learn from and understand it is
amazing that
we can leverage such expertise
and investment of others into generating
high quality data sets
really generated from like i mentioned
cell lines
animal models as well as patients but
the problem is really
that we need to learn how to navigate
this data right so
here in this image you can see this is
mapping of
reads to the reference you know right
every single box right here represents a
piece of data
so working with this data and making it
useful really extracting some meaningful
insights
is challenging and that is why
we can hear about all of these exciting
methods
people you know doing amazing projects
and maybe
integrating a lot of this data and
running all kinds of artificial
intelligence
on it and the problem is that it seems
out of reach
right it is just complex because you
have to deal with
huge amounts of data and very
complicated methods so how do you get
trained how do you get
into something like that or if you're
already in it how do you expand your
horizons so that you can actually
leverage some of these more advanced
methods and
speed up the process of utilizing
bioinformatics
to actually ask such questions and do
some kind of meaningful work
in this field and so our solution to
this is to
try and make tools for analysis and
integration of this data more user
friendly
and to train people with the logic
behind
how these tools work so that anyone can
play around with big data sets analyzing
and
integrating them together asking
research questions that make sense
and that will essentially help you
understand both the data and the
computational approaches in a better way
and so what i mean by that
is that we built the logic of analysis
into the toolkit that we have and we'll
talk briefly about some of the resources
that you'll have access to
in this program where the logic is
explained in courses
and applied in a meaningful way in a
computational
big data analysis platform that you can
point and click
getting quickly from raw data sets to
structured data sets
developing tests and annotating
annotating them with biological
information so that you can quickly go
from raw data available on these public
repositories
to biologically meaningful results and
so this kind of annotation
i think provides us with an opportunity
to make
complicated methods that ultimately
are required to make sense of this data
easily approachable
and we can now take examples from real
studies
that will allow us to ask these
questions and understand
what other understand what others have
done for example
availability of the cancer genome atlas
or the tcga
really is one of those examples where we
can
source multi-omics data from 12
different tumor types
with thousands of patients that have
information about their
clinical stage about the different types
of tumors about the different types of
treatments that they received and even
comorbidities in many cases
and start asking meaningful questions
about
how that data could be used to inform
the classification of patients the
treatment strategy
the prevention the risk right so all of
these important questions could be asked
not only that we will also take a look
at some examples where
cancer studies using patient-derived
cell lines could be used to
train mathematical models using machine
learning and classification
to start predicting different classes
based on signatures
or specific molecular biomarkers
we will also dive deeper into some of
the clinical
data for risk factors and outcomes we'll
take a look at
publications and top journals like cell
and
nature medicine that actually show us
how do people utilize some of these
types of data
to come up with new computational
methods but also
how to apply known bioinformatics
approaches that you will learn
in this program to extract meaningful
insights
so cancer obviously is one of those
examples
another example a type of diseases that
we know
is infectious disease is also a growing
area where
molecular precision is becoming more and
more informative and i'll give you just
a quick example
we all are hearing about these new
variants coming up in different strains
of
coronavirus all the time and what we
know now
is that these strains are defined by
mutations
and those mutations have a critical
impact on the rollout of vaccines right
we actually hear about that every day in
the news
and it's amazing that today genomic data
is so easy to talk about
even though just five years ago you
would start talking about genomic
mutations
and people would just stop listening to
you right so we live in an
era of genomic data becoming more and
more
relevant to everything that we interact
with and so this
application of molecular biomarkers
and genomic variants to insights that
have a practical public health
and also clinical impact and
significance is now
very obvious so this program is going to
talk about
some applications of uh computational
methods
to a variety of clinical biomedical
research
pharma and biotechnology challenges
using
big data that is sourced from
peer-reviewed journals
and found in different repositories that
anyone
can get data from and it is going to be
oriented towards
where this field is going and it's
obvious that this field
is going towards big data where
data mining and classification methods
are becoming
more and more user-friendly and easy to
apply to these data sets
extracting meaningful signal from that
data is becoming
easier but at the same time what you
really need is you need the logic of
bridging the gap between the biomedical
and the clinical applications of this
data
to the actual methodology so that the
two can be used together in a meaningful
way
and so in this program we're going to go
through a lot of these examples
with some also technical practical
training that you can get
access to how to perform many of these
analytical approaches on our big data
analysis platform
including in r and python learning from
curated examples and then developing
a sense of a computational process where
you go from raw data
all the way to biologically meaningful
insight
and taking that with you so that you can
start developing a an environment for
yourself where you can easily
leverage this data for meaningful
biological and biomedical research
and so some of the outcomes that we
envision for those that are joining this
program is to understand scientific
literature that describes
analysis of omics data to know how to do
basic processing steps for next
generation sequencing data analysis
with consistent accuracy and meaningful
approaches
to perform exploratory analysis and
generate a hypothesis from data
to design contrast for statistical tests
and prepare data for machine learning
annotate found signal using biological
datasets and references
identify appropriate datasets for
answering a biological question
how to plan a bioinformatics analysis
from start to finish in an independent
way
and then how to present a project
proposal including the rationale
the methods scientific background and
anticipated results
and so this if this is relevant for you
and i want to mention that
we've previously had hundreds of people
finish this program and really taken
away
meaningful training skills that they
could later apply
to a variety of challenges that they
face
in their own research and so that
includes
many different participants of different
backgrounds including
high school students that are ambitious
and want to get
into a program with an advanced project
that they can
present includes undergraduates that
are learning something relevant and
really want to get ahead and maybe want
to prepare for their master's studies or
they want to go into a more
data driven field that includes phd
students and postdocs
that are now engaged in different types
of data analysis projects
and they need the skill set and the
tools and resources to make their
understanding of their project more data
driven and apply these tools in a
meaningful way
and of course researchers and faculty
that are also
trying to leverage bioinformatics to
make their research more impactful
so now i would like to pass it on to
uh gipoliano chavez he's going to be one
of our mentors in this program that you
will be able to interact with and if you
are interested in developing a research
project
work with him on that part of it but
also hear from
his experience in research and i know
that geopoliano
you come not from a bioinformatics
background you actually learned
bioinformatics as you were getting
interested
in uh your research topic so i'm excited
to have you here and maybe you could
share a little bit more about
your research interests as well thank
you everyone
thank you thank you elia for this very
nice
introduction i am going to share my
screen now
you all see my screen correct
okay yes we can see it thank you i think
i said your name
incorrectly it's elia i'm sorry
no so good morning everybody my name is
gipoliono
currently i am at the university of
chicago
and i'm going to talk to you a little
bit today
about the challenges that i
face on my research and really
based on what elia said that i do not
come from bioinformatics background
i want to give you an idea of how you
can get introduced to that
and how you can get started with that so
to start i'd like to
tell you a little bit about my mentoring
experience i have been a mentor at this
point
in the summer internship program at the
university of california santa cruz
where
where i got my phd from i was a mentor
there for us
five or six years and in the right part
here
you can see that i not only mentor high
school students the sip
of the c public the the cohort that
of students that use to
take part on the summer internship
program is basically formed of high
school students but it is
it is really really great to also mentor
and have the opportunity to interact
with uh the early educational uh
students at
ucsc my my son is actually part of this
cohort here when we were
touring them and showing a little bit of
science of what what it is to be a
science what it looks like to be a
scientist
and so it was really really nice to have
these kids interact with the lab
so with all this experience i think it's
very important to have a sense of
community for the human
development in any area that you work in
anything that you do
and particularly in this field that we
are at the
the bioinformatics field it is also
important to teach
uh kids and adults computational
concepts
because it's a form of investment in
their lives as we said i come from
an undergraduate background where i
didn't have any exposure to
computational programming so it's really
important to provide
people with that type of training in a
field of science that in my
uh in my mind and i guess many of you
would agree with me is so needed these
days
so for many of us uh and for me
particularly a computational algorithm
is a thing that
i never use it to think five
years ago for instance before before
that i never use it to really think
about what a computational algorithm is
but really today i would like to give
you a very
uh general idea of what a computational
algorithm is
it is a basically a set of rules uh to
be followed in calculations
to obtain uh results from uh
as an an output from a given input
so you basically have some sort some
piece of data
you give it to a computational algorithm
and you get
a result out of it and thank you alia so
much because you
talked about this concept of
falsification how it is so important in
cancer and in these advanced genomic
studies
but really i like to start from the very
simple principles of of science
and i guess we have been using these uh
some sort of pacification for a really
really long time here
this example of classifying for instance
animals
so we can for instance think about
classifying the animals based on their
number of
uh feet and i hope i'm saying that
correctly in english
so here we have animals with two feet
and here we have those animals with four
feet and this is a
system of clustering or classification
like we we
could argue that in that in that regard
a
classification system like classifying
animals by their species
is a more refined way of classification
uh compared to clustering but really we
are talking about
grouping subgroups
based on similarities that they have
so how can we get started with this
computational classification i would say
that we are so interested in
first i would say it is really really
important to
identify a problem as i am going to tell
you the problem that i work with
is cancer particularly neuroblastoma
which is a
pediatric cancer
the other thing that i would say is
important is to identify
a sponsor so a mentor a school
or a group a science group that you
might be interested in
and uh really the
what you need is someone or an
institution that has the potential
to guide you through the process and
frankly
i joined omixlogic a couple of weeks ago
i'm still
getting used to all the resources that
they have but
so far i think the resources that i have
seen and have
tested and use it they they're very very
valuable
resources in the bioinformatics field
so i said that it is important to
identify a problem that you're
interested in and the one that i
told you i am interested in is
neuroblastoma it's a complex
or polygenic disease uh i'll not go
too much into details but i want to say
that it's
a problem in the development of the
sympathetic
nervous system so the sympathetic
nervous system is this part of the
nervous system that connects organs to
the central nervous system here
in the spine for instance as you can see
the other problem that i want to go to
in neuroblastoma
is this concept that we have two major
populations in the tumor so we have
the whole mass of the tumor uh
there we could argue that there are many
sub populations but
i am going to talk tell you about the
two main subgroups the two major
populations which
are the population of adrenergic cells
that look actually like neurons that's
why
you see these projections from the
cytoplasm of the cells
making them really look like neurons and
we have them as in camel cells
which do not have these progression
these projections
they are not they do not adhere sorry
they adhere very tightly
to substrate that's why they have this
name of s-type which
means substrate adherent but the
difference between these cells is that
the adrenergic cells are really
differentiated
and the mesenchymal cells are not
differentiated
you can also think of them as cells with
a
stem stemness potential very high
so these mesenchymal cells are not
differentiated
they are not sensitive to chemotherapy
they do not die upon chemotherapy
and they lead to this concept of minimal
residual disease
which is the concept that after you give
chemotherapy treatment to
the cells the chemotherapy is going to
kill the adrenergic cells but not the
mesenchymal
and the mesenchymal cells have the
ability to differentiate into
adrenergic cells and that there we have
a problem because
the chemotherapy is not going to kill
the cells and so there is a chance that
the disease
is going to come back and when the
disease progresses or relapses
there is an enrichment of the
mesenchymal cells
it is really important to classify
neuroblastoma tumors and i'm going to
give you a more detailed idea of what
that looks like it's really important to
classify the tumors
into adrenergic mesenchymal because that
has
a potential for prognosis but so far
i mean that's the part of research that
i do here this
slide shows you what uh really the
ultimate level
of uh prognosis is in neuroblastoma
so uh a neuroblastoma tumor is really
classified
uh into high risk and non-high risk
neuroblastoma so the high risk
has a very lower survival probability
compared to
non-high risk and really one
important problem is that after a child
is the tumor of a child is
classified as a highly risk
neuroglostonic there are no methods to
determine whether
that disease will progress or not
so measuring as i said the mesenchymal
cells may provide prognostic ability to
the research
and mesenchymal cell quantification can
be done by sequencing
of epigenetic profiles
so clustering consists on the
identification of homogeneous groups
among a set of heterogeneous pythons
in the specific case of neuroblastoma
what i
try what i do is i classify cell lines
or tumors based on their gene expression
profiles
the other thing that i have worked with
is classification
of sarskoftu sarskovic ii
uh based on their mutational profiles
you will agree with me that mutations
are important in cancer
and are also important in orbit 19.
so for neuroblastoma this is an example
of what's going on right now
in the field because what people try to
do is to classify
these adrenergic cells and the
mesenchymal cells this is a machine
learning method called hierarchical
clustering
so we can basically separate classify or
clusterize
the adrenergic and mesenchymal cells we
can do the same
using um what are called wet lab methods
such as a western blot this is a
biochemical method of protein
quantification
and you can use some scoring systems
to classify adrenergic and mesenchymal
cells based
also on their gene expression profiles
this image here
in the right is a similar method this is
also a hierarchical clustering method
but this is based on uh enhancer
enhancer peaks or enhance cis regulatory
regions and the enhanced regions that we
use to
classify or differentiate the adrenergic
and mesenchymal cells
so what i do currently is i
basically score tumors so what you see
here in the left
are 498 tumors
classified with a high mesenchymal score
top high second highest mesenchymal
stock
high highest ms and camel score third
highest missing
most score and fourth highest missing
camo score which is the basically
the lowest missing camera scores and
what we can
demonstrate or see is that as tumors
with high amazing chemospores they have
a lower survival probability here i'm
looking at all risks
but there is some evidence that when i
look at the high risk of work
that cohort also has a lower survival
probability and so this is
showing some evidence that the
classification
of tumors based on their epigenetic
profiles may allow
uh some prognosis analysis in high-risk
neuroblastoma and this is very important
because as i said
for high-risk neuroblastoma there's no
such a prognosis system yet
and that's what we're working with so i
am
going to end now my talk by showing you
one thing that is really interesting in
my opinion which is the fact that we can
compare
these very different types of diseases
on the right i have
a heat map of neuroblastoma this is
using the
uh rnac profile of neurobaston
sorry if i said this is the left this is
the right the right image
the in the left side here we have a heat
map
showing the mutational profile of kovid
19.
so with the high school students that i
told you we
developed these uh classification system
uh of cov19 based on
the mutational profiles so here what's
interesting to note is that by looking
at the frequency of these mutations we
see
some sort of clusterization of the
mutations that are
in the extreme or extreme east
of the earth such as the samples
collected from china
also present in the bat and the bengal
in which
uh which are thought to be the animals
that are
um more permanent hosts of of the virus
so really here what i want to say is
that uh
computational biology methods allow us
to compare
or to uh have a sense of common analysis
that can be done in in two completely
different diseases such as neuroblastoma
and covid19 so in conclusion
as i said bioinformatics can be used to
study and understand these
two very different diseases and many
other types of different diseases as
we saw in during this presentation
and more specifically in my case
bioinformatics may allow the development
of prognosis system for
high risk near blossom so i would like
to
end now thank you so much for listening
for the opportunity to talk here
thank you so much dr liano for
yes sorry thank you thank you so much dr
jebuliano for
uh sharing uh your research
it really sounds very interesting now i
would want to
uh welcome dr harpreet our mentor for
the program
to please introduce herself over to you
dr albree
ah nalika can you give me some time
actually my sister is a bit hacked
yes ma'am sure no issues at all uh
doctor mo
uh now i would want to ask dr mohammad
mazumba to please
uh share the session details
[Music]
uh okay thank you
snalika and hello everyone
so um before i
share the session details i would like
to thank uh india for this excellent
overview
and uh it helped us learn a lot of new
things
and giopilanio also for the introduction
to the
to the research now
i'd like to share my screen to show you
some of the resources that are
associated with the program
and it's just for everyone i think
uh because uh we do hear uh about some
of the
confusion that are there with all the
resources that have been shared
so i just wanted uh all of us to go
through some of these resources and to
understand where to find
uh the the things that we discussed
today
so this is the pre-registration page
where we all started and like many of
you have pre-registered here
so in this page uh we have a video
overview
and then we have the session details um
along with that there's a form that you
have many of you have filled up and
then we send out the emails so uh
when you go through this page and uh
you would want to learn more about the
sessions so the second thing that i
would like to take you to is the program
syllabus
and how we have planned the live
sessions and the resources that are
associated with it
so one of the exciting part of this
program is just
which also differentiates us from other
other similar
similar you know online programs is that
uh there are several
uh resources that are associated with
each of the programs so this is
the syllabus page and uh
if you can paste the link of this page
too so that we can all browse through
this page
so um as as we go to this page this page
actually describes the the curriculum
that we have developed and also uh the
resources that would be associated
including the assignments the hands-on
sessions and what will be covered in the
hands-on sessions
and uh where would you learn about those
technologies and what all elia just said
about
you know getting started with uh with
big data getting started with
uh gene expression data getting started
with um
uh genomic data and then applying it for
uh
for cancer problem and applying it for
infectious diseases
so there's a lot to learn and there is
so i mean i'm really
happy that we have all of you to get
together today
to showcase some of these that we have
put together for this program so there's
a video uh
again uh which gives an overview of what
was covered so you have already seen
what was covered
so session wise when we go to the
when we will start which would be on
tuesday so we are going to start next
tuesday uh at uh
9 30 a.m cst i think it's 10 10 mcst
so yeah so in the first session we will
be covering about bioinformatics and
translational oncology
research so this would be the overview
of
uh of the cancer problem as we were
discussing we will discuss about the
complexity
in the sense of how it is being
described in
a tissue organ and you know
cell cellular level and then the
molecular factors that
actually are associated with tumor
development growth and metastasis
then we will understand that the how how
genotypic and phenotypic
relationship can be identified through
these clinical and molecular data types
and then we will go through the
uh the overview of the platform and what
we will be
doing throughout the course so this will
be on the on the
on the first session which will also be
available uh
to all of you and uh the
the associated online resources as i was
telling you that
um at we started off with
the learn site so let me go to the learn
site
this is the associated uh associated
courses that are available on the learn
site
so if you have not created a login for
yourself
so please do that this is the
link and let me show you how you can do
that it's very simple and
this is also for to uh to also for those
who would not
uh who who are participants who would be
participants and also for those who
would think about joining later but
uh you know it's great to have you here
it's a free login
so you can just log in with your email
address or your
social media address so i'll just sign
in
so once i sign in i'll come to the home
page
i'll just show you how to navigate
through this website
so once you come to the homepage it
describes all of what we described
and talked discussed today as well as uh
what are different specialization that
you can opt for
so we have specializations in oncology
infectious neuroscience agriculture
and then the t by info server and uh
also
all of the things that we discussed our
associations
and then uh the interesting thing about
the syllabus is that we will
start with introduction to
bioinformatics so let's go to our first
course
introduction to bioinformatics which
will be covered in the first session
so in the first session we would want to
learn uh we would all want to learn
about
where bioinformatics can be applied uh
especially in biomedical research
so all the areas that you might be
interested in you will be able to
navigate through this
and this uh this course also has a form
which let us
uh let let us uh know
more about you about your research
interest so this is a course that i
recommend you
all to take and it's a free course so
once you create your
login here your free login here you can
start taking this course uh
after your login is done and you have a
profile
so let me quickly show you what our
profile is profile looks like so this is
my academic profile
i have a image and i have uh i've
described myself
so one of the benefits of having a
profile is that
you will be able to see your progress
how many courses you have finished how
many programs that you are enrolled
in and also like uh what are the as i
said that what are the courses that i'm
enrolled in i'm doing
and what are the programs i'm enrolled
in and i'm like interested in going
through
and then the certifications that i have
that i've gained from
uh taking the courses these courses are
completing the programs
so all of this you will gain and get
from this
profile once you just create a free
profile here and put some of the
information that would help us
learn more about you and also like uh
like also people who are interested to
collaborate with you
or people who are interested to hire you
for uh any
specific research work so all of that is
actually the components of having uh the
profile
so this i would really recommend you to
all of you to
create and at least go through the free
resources that are available with all of
the sessions
so as i said that the first session that
would be about introduction to
bioinformatics and introduction to
cancer the second session is more
technical where we dive into
genomics so uh in genomics we will learn
about next generation sequencing we will
learn about how we can
how we can analyze genomic data and find
out those
variants and those variations and those
mutations significant mutations
so again there is a bunch of courses
that explains genomics and
one of the benefits of doing this is not
just that you
would be able to learn from the very
beginning from the very basic
starting with the dna structure but also
you will have an option to work
and learn our and apply our or python
using our coding playground tutorials
so here you i will show you another
demonstration
where you will able to also apply data
science techniques
so about genomics uh you will be also go
be able to go through
the hands-on sessions and the hands-on
sessions with
the star mark are the ones that are
available
to the participants and also to those
who would want to subscribe
for the asynchronous material so uh when
i click into this i'll get information
about how i can prepare my pipeline and
understand about the process of creating
a pipeline and
what are the components that are
involved so once you complete this is
like an achievement that i've gone
through this tutorial and
i have gone through this tutorial so uh
but not uh yet on the platform so
here you will also learn about the data
sets that are embedded in the
with the link that you will get so these
are all the benefits of uh
getting to the to the asynchronous
material and going through the tutorials
and that goes from you know basic
introduction
to building up variation variant
pipelines to do a phylogenetic analysis
and again uh go through multiple
sequence alignment
to see the variation and evolution of
genomes
so obviously there are so many
applications which i cannot list out
in this session however the second
session and the third session after the
second session learning about genomics
would be about transcriptomics data so
gene expression data
here also we will go through uh the an
overview of
how you uh i mean what is the
significance what is rna sequencing why
it is done
um its history and then about its uh
application that how do you do it and
uh like get uh understanding about the
quality of the file
that are available and then how do you
pre-process the data
map it to the genome and going through
all that uh process
so we will be doing this on the t-band
for platform
so just let me quickly uh go to the
t-band for platform
so sorry about this this is a different
pipeline
so this is the tibia info platform which
we discussed
in this meeting and which is a really
amazing platform which is a very
comprehensive as well
describes all of the ngs data data types
and
shows us very elaborated methods and
pipelines
to uh you know analyze this sort of data
so uh
this is a typical pipeline this is how
it looks and
uh one of the best part of this is that
it's uh
the entire platform is very uh you know
friendly because it describes all of the
processes all of the data types
that are there and uh what are the
applications that we can do with this
so when we go into this section this is
about transcriptomics and i was
discussing
session about the transcriptomics so
here
uh we will be going through the
the example data sets that we have
compiled for you and learn from
so this is a pipeline which has already
uh
build data sets which are put together
and you will be learning about those
data sets in the session
and then we will be going through the
pipeline together building a pipeline
how
how this you know format makes sense why
these
uh these are placed in this manner so
the flow is that that these algorithms
are placed in
i know many of you are already aware of
this but for those who are not
are in a logical manner put together in
a logical manner
where we start from pre-processing the
data to then error connect correction
then maybe mapping it to the genome or
you know
doing isoform construction or doing uh
mapping it to the transcriptome
or doing differential gene expression so
there are several experiments i mean
you can build from different paths that
you can take
to analyze your data so in this uh
in this session we will be learning
about the breast cancer
sample cell lines that we discussed and
the publication that is associated with
the session
so i think i can i can go about it a
little bit more but
i i think we don't have that much time
but coming to the
part where we will be discussing about
uh the application
and there was a question about
classification and clustering
in the chat i think it is something that
also i would love to talk more and more
about but we already have a session
described for this where we will be
going through machine learning
and in this we will be applying gene
expression data
and finding patterns from the gene
expression data so
uh in this process we will be applying
um
machine learning methods using the tb
for server obviously
so we have those very well defined in
these sections of data mining so you
will be able to
do clustering and pca and also
if network but yeah you can start
with all of these methods or when you
start with uh the program and also like
uh to those who are joining uh
i think it's great to start with the
coursework and get a glimpse of
uh the sessions before actually the
start of the program
so now i would also want to tell you
more about a little bit of machine
learning in biomedical data
and data science uh so how what is the
data science aspect
so um sorry
let's go back to the courses
and let me search for data science
so we have a lot of data science courses
and
one of the example i would want to show
you is that introduction to data science
for r so here we have a lot of tutorials
uh that you will be able to go through
and it's relevant to the session
uh so we will be going through some of
the visualization
techniques how would we do pca and com
using our code so as you as i as i said
that um our studio is
is available here on the browser
so you can actually learn about the
problem here
and then learn about the data that is
available
and then uh the the
the commands where it is described what
it
it explains like uh what data set that
we are
taking what kind of uh uh what kind of
uh step that we are doing so here
uh once you learn about these steps and
learn about
what will be done with the data you will
have an opportunity to do it
do it yourself so
it's a big tutorial
so learning about all these techniques
uh going through the assignments and
you'll be able to run it yourself so
this is a code block
where this uh you can run the scripts by
learning
about the scripts and then actually uh
doing it yourself and
getting results so for the data sets
that uh
maybe our researchers are working on our
research fellows are working on
they're utilizing these these tools to
come up with uh
with images and for presentations and
publications etc so this was about
that and then the fifth session is about
oncology where we will be learning about
the data sorry oncology data sources so
it's more about the data
repositories so we will be going to ncbi
we will be looking at the data sets that
are available there learning from them
uh taking some of them as examples and
understanding how
they connect i mean how do you annotate
your results better
so how do you annotate your mutations
how do you annotate
what in information that you're getting
out of the machine learning
after the machine learning analysis so
this is the first phase
uh after the first phase second phase is
all about infectious disease problems
in this we will be learning about viral
genomes
and host transcriptomes so we have
also virology sections that will be
utilized in this program
uh so um so going back to that
so here we will have examples projects
in this style
from this part you will start working on
projects you will have an opportunity to
start working on projects
so these projects are asynchronous
projects that you can take any time
and you will have an opportunity to work
them through
when you have uh availability
and these are like very descriptive
projects that describes
uh i mean these are some of the data
sets that
are described by publications and we
have put together how do you analyze and
uh understand from what uh the authors
have described
so uh these are some of the example
projects
and then we will learn about uh genomic
uh
multiple sequence alignment and
phylogeny and we have another few
projects like kuvin19 and ebola
so these are again about the mutations
and uh how
how kobe 19 or i mean this is from a
paper
uh that describes the proximal origin of
starscope 2 it was published in nature
medicine 2020
um so yeah you will learn about go
this you can learn from this project as
well along with the session
so these are the live sessions that we
will be covering and along with that
there are always
uh asynchronous material available for
you to take
throughout the week and then we will go
through project examples
where we will learn how to compare uh
and i mean these are different
biological questions that we are asking
from the data
so that you get an experience of how can
you ask your question
from your research so again
like after learning about all of this uh
the
last part of the session the 10th
session is about host pathogen
interaction
so here we will learn and connect uh
some of the aspects of
our omics data to structure and uh you
know finding those
key mutations and understanding those
and
then the effect of what it caused for
the
function of the protein so this is what
is planned for this
precision medicine program and i hope
that
i've been able to describe this well
to all of you and i'll be happy to
answer any questions that you have
and also i wanted to add that signing up
on the learn
hope that is learn.omicslogic.com
would get you the automatic access of
the tby
info server as well which dr mohaj just
shared
and uh yes so we also share i
i will be mailing you all the details
which were
uh discussed in the session and also
would give you the links and how you can
proceed further with your
submission right so thank you sonalika i
just wanted to add a couple of things so
we also have a slack channel
and i forgot to mention about the
program uh part
so yeah when you go to learn and when
you do this
login you'll be able to go to this tab
programs
so in programs we have all the programs
listed out that are upcoming or have
been ongoing
so you will find precision medicine here
and to register for this program
uh with live sessions and everything not
just the asynchronous material
you have to start your application so
using this link
and once you start your application you
can select different options
so these options involve all the cloud
access so there are five terabyte of
space that would be allocated
uh and you will be able to run the cloud
pipelines and then the coding sessions
all of this is included in this uh in
this in this patch
package and here uh you will be also
able to apply some of the discount codes
or
some of the fee waivers that have been
provided by sunalika
and also for lower income countries we
have a scholarship option
that is also available and i would like
to request those who are applying for
scholarship to do it
as soon as possible because we are going
to start the program on tuesday so we
can process your application by
monday so i would also request sonalika
to share the
scholarship scholarship link so there
are different access
levels so different licenses another
license is about the intermediate step
step where you would want to have an
additional one-on-one mentor support
where you would want to go through some
of the materials along with the mentor
ask your research question so even in
this entire program and even in the
webinars that we do
uh it would be really nice to discuss
your research question but yeah
obviously
there's a limitation of time but when
you are in one of the programs then it
would be
uh it would give us like a lot of time
for uh you
with you to discuss your research and
work on your idea
and if we can utilize these resources to
be able to come up with the research
outcome
so the research part uh is also
being in this advanced license so it
gets you to work on
your own project an additional month of
cloud access so this is the advanced
license and then obviously there you'll
have access to a lot of courses and
then once you go into the sessions and
like register for the program
you will be able to see a different
interface and so i'll take you there but
you will also be able to come up and
it will also be able to get your
certificate as i showed you earlier
so this is the registration part and
along with this
uh now let's let me show you i'm not
registered for this program so i would
just want to show you
another program and the interface so
once you're registered this is the
interface that you get
so you will get uh the courses that
you're doing and all of that and you can
ask for a q a or you can ask for a
mentor session
and then you'll get your certificates
here and uh when the sessions are
ongoing you will find the session videos
here so the recording video recording
you will get into
when you get uh registered and then you
will have access to an interface like
this
and then you will be able to get the
session recordings
into this interface so that you wouldn't
have to you know go anywhere it's just
in
same place where you will find all the
details so also the same thing
with for the zoom link for the next
session you will be able to find the
zoom link as well
so this is another program that is
ongoing for our partners in
louisiana so it's a program with lvrn
network
uh so i think yeah and that's it uh
that i wanted to uh to tell you all
uh if there are any questions i'll be
happy to answer those and now i would
also like to invite
um also like to invite dr harpreet to
tell more about herself
thank you doctor murray let me share my
screen
answering your question vipre yes the
sessions would be recorded and they
would be
uh given the access to all the program
participants
yes dr harpreet you may continue thank
you
thank you sunalika so hello everyone my
name is
harvey kor i have a phd in
bioinformatics
so my phd was in the area of cancer
genomics
particularly liver cancer so my phd
sorry so the major areas that i
uh i have worked on during my phd that
was
uh biomarker discovery for the diagnosis
and the prognosis of the liver cancer
here i have mainly focused on accurate
cancer prediction particularly first
fatal cellular carcinoma which is
primary liberal malignancy and the
second chlangiocarcinoma
which is ah another primary labor
pregnancy
then and another area where i have
worked that is i have
to identify important uh genomics and
epigenomics biomarker
for the early prediction of scc basin in
the third
in the next project i have worked on the
area to stratify
hcc patients of based on their
reoccurrence
that is whether there is a low
reoccurrence risk or
high occurrence risk so in my current
role
i uh i'm i'm in my current role i'm
current column developer
and uh
so i'm involved in designing research
project and assisting the uh
assisting the participants in their
various types of analysis i'm also
mentioning number of the research follow
in their research process
so i'm looking forward to work with you
uh during this
upcoming program so now over to you for
alika
thank you so much dr thank you so much
dr harpreet
and thank you everyone for joining today
and if you have any questions you may
mail me at
marketing at the refine dot bio
or you you can also mail dr mohit at
mohit at the refine dot bio
and we have shared all the details with
you i i will be sharing the
uh session recording as well the webinar
we had to do the recording of the
webinar and also all the details
including the program registration page
and the pre-registration page as well
and i've shared the mails if you have
any doubts you
you can ask us thank you so much
everyone for joining